your mom she's a character she doesn't
sound like she's always
easy but you are working with her
oh she is co-hosting to tell the truth
with you
yeah i couldn't do that i could not work
side by side with one of my parents i
love them but they couldn't do that
what's it like how did she get this gig
you know what uh
i had already had the gig we hadn't
started production yet
uh and i got a call that steve harvey
wanted me to do celebrity family feud
and i was like okay cool so i bring my
mom
uh my brother my sister-in-law and my
aunt
and so it's the five of us and the first
question out of the gate
where would a naked magician pull a
rabbit out of and i'm up there with
steve another contestant with my hand
but
boom i hit the buzzer first anthony i
was like his ass steve
boom number one answer all right yeah
turn to my mom and then hey
we gonna steve we're going to play so we
go back
known steve 25 years he's known my mom
just as long so there's a
there's a relationship there so he knows
something wild is about to come out of
my mother's mouth he's like miss doris
uh question to you is where would a
naked magician pull a rabbit out of and
she looks steve dead in his eye and says
his nuts steve it's nuts
that's not possible exactly
steve cries shuts down production for
maybe
five to seven minutes the crowd is going
crazy we gather ourselves
of course the answer's not up there we
end up losing to tony braxton and her
family
as one as one does yes so the producers
come over
who actually produce family feud they
produce it's fremantle they produce
uh to tell the truth they're anthony
we'd like to talk to you about your mom
i was like guys
i'm sorry i told you she was a live wire
i was like you know what
you never know what's gonna come out my
mama i'll talk to her everything's cool
and i'm like no
no no no we loved what she said we loved
what she did
what do you think about her your mom
being your co-host
oh wow on to tell the truth i was like i
think you can write a bigger check than
i can and i'm all cool
this is great this is going to take care
of all your problems yeah and
and that is how my mom got on to tell
the truth
good for her and we've been rocking out
for
six seasons now that's incredible yeah
yeah
and so she's able to travel is she
blowing a lot of that money on bingo or
uh you know remarkably not my
my mother has never been one to save
money you know as soon as she gets it it
goes out and that's why we never had
anything as kids growing up but that's
another
story for another couch and another
therapist yeah yeah
um but no so my mom's
my mom has done well yeah she's been
able to save
uh she's been able to get her credit
right she's been able to uh
get a financial plan in order uh and
she's about to buy her own her own home
and
have money in the bank so yeah she's
learned it it took 67 years but it
she's learned you should start hitting
her up for money ah she would never give
it to me
conan my mother would my mother would
call me at
you know when i had the height of me
making movies
um let's say kangaroo jack kangaroo jack
made a hundred million dollars
my mother always thought that hundred
million dollars the vast majority of
that went to me
yes so my mother would call me she said
boy kangaroo daddy at 100 million
you think you can let me hold 50 000. no
mama
that's not how it works it's not how it
works it's actually my mother would call
me for 50 grand at a time conan
yeah yeah you got to move around fast
you got to change your number yeah
make it very hard